to be honest i miss those girls they
were like my sisters and i'm just so
grateful
that um time heals all wounds tamar
let's get into it let's talk about why
we're here today
you are a judge on be go live
explain to me what this is what beagle
idol is and how he got roped into it
okay first of all i love an amazing
competition show
and i also have recently fallen in love
with the app
and people just really sign up basically
just to showcase their talent
and what i'm looking for is star quality
originality and just that zing
you know we all need to have that zing
and so that's exactly what i'm looking
for i
can not wait for this event and i'm so
glad that i get to be
um the finalists judge to
help determine who is the winner of lego
live all right you are about to light up
the internet with this competition
but you lit up the comment sections
on instagram recently yeah yeah you
dropped into tamara's
uh comment section and people went nuts
were you surprised at how many people
paid attention to that
i actually was it was actually a dream
right
because for a while um tamara and our
relationship has been so strange we
stopped following each other on social
media and
when i tell you it was really a moment
that i captured of the two of them and
it just really reminded me of old
times that was so beautiful and so
magical and i remember i used to be a
part of that and um
to be honest i missed those girls they
were like my sisters
and so when i saw that moment i just
reacted
out of you know what i saw and um you
know it really did
help rekindle um tamara and my
relationship
i'm really so happy that i got a chance
to talk to her
and text with her and catch up with her
and i'm just so grateful
that um time heals all wounds and you
know we have a chance to
really grow up and stay under
construction and elevate to the next
level of our lives
subtle plug for the podcast there under
construction
you know i saw that going down in the
comment section and i went you know what
we need on under construction
real ladies reunion slash therapy
session
oh my god well you know to be honest i
really you know hope to um rekindle all
my relationships and then
um we can probably do something for the
public but i think
personally there's a lot of things that
needs to be said and you know not a lot
of hugs that
needs to be had and these are like you
know really old wounds that you know
that run really deep because we really
truly loved each other
and i don't know you know you never know
what healed these wounds or what moved
the healing of these wounds was it just
time to be honest it definitely was new
information
i heard that that network that i was
working with at the time would not sign
off
and allowed me and them girls to
fall out in public and allowed lonnie to
take the fall
adrian genie tamara and
myself and we up here battling and
fighting and black ass black girls and
they don't care
however you know me on my journey i just
don't kind of i don't really want to get
into he said she said that say right
um because i think that's falling into
old habits but what i do
know um about me is that um forgiveness
is a big part of my life and if i'm
asking
those to forgive me for you know the
times when i was
immature or the times i didn't truly
understand situations
um i can only pass that on and that's
what i want to do so
even if that means that i have to reach
out first that's fine with me
so you want to do get it settled in
private and then maybe
we'll do something in public whether
that be on the podcast or maybe a return
to the reel for you as a guest
i don't know about that because cam damn
is not there anymore you know
so it really kind of won't be the same
but at the end of the day i am
grateful to have rekindled my
relationships
with the ladies that i've already
rekindled my relationships with and you
know who knows about the future you know
we just cross our fingers and you know
be our better self
well hopefully they'll be back in studio
soon then we can have that conversation
when that happens
the world is starting to get back a
little bit to normal
you are getting to go on a stage this
weekend i believe
and perform for the people what does
that mean to you
oh my god i mean i guess for all
performers it's been almost two years
since we've been able to perform
and i guess i should let the cat out of
the bag my first performance
will actually be at lenethia lounge
which is nene's lounge officially opens
this weekend and i will be there on
saturday night
to crescent her stage and perform for
her and all of her fans and all of my t
martian atlanta fans
and then i move on to texas and then who
knows let's open up the floodgates you
know everybody
has you know been able to get vaccined
and outside is opening up and we live in
our best summer 21 life honey
maxed waxed ready to rock it out at your
concert
is new music on the way it definitely is
i'm so excited um i'm actually doing two
new albums and listen it is
i've said this before this is my best
work yet but this is my best
tamar yet so therefore this is my super
best work yet
this is me living in my truth being
being you know this new tamar this new
found
a relationship with myself and i'm
really loving the music that's coming
out of me now
it's great is it all music you've you've
written
and produced kind of in these last few
months of figuring out
your new self or is this like because i
remember we talked a year ago
which was a different time yeah and you
had new music and
you were working on stuff then yeah and
i would imagine maybe that music
is not the music you want to put out now
well absolutely not
but you always want me to still see
right
so i can't give up you know i can't give
it all away but i do
definitely speak about uh those dark
times and definitely those times where
i need help needed help and didn't know
how to cry out for it
and so it's a lot of inspirational
magical
um songs that will really you know help
people
who don't know who to turn to and you
know need
needs to be healed and don't know how to
heal and so
um these are two amazing albums without
telling you
exactly what they are but i definitely
know that
this music now will for sure he'll heal
your soul
and that's what i'm here for okay i'm
picking up that like maybe a record
might be a gospel-leaning one
i'm gonna poke around here tabar i don't
know
bryce we have to wait you have to see
you know but just like
any other time i definitely won't
disappoint you never do
it has been a year for you ups downs and
all the in-betweens
what have you learned about yourself in
this last year specifically
oh this last year wow um
for me it it has been to keep going
move forward you know um i keep thinking
about you know if
when i when i felt so dark and so lost
and so alone
if something would have happened to me
um i keep remembering that tomorrow
would have
gone on anyway so why not
keep living keep pushing forward even
even when you don't understand
um you keep pushing forward and i'm so
happy that i did
i'm so happy that you know i'm doing the
work and i've done so much work
um because i can live to tell about it
and i can also live
to help someone else who don't have the
tools that i now have so
keep pushing forward you know i asked
you a similar question
last year about like what you've learned
about yourself and
now we know you had a mask up at the
time you were not telling the truth yeah
i'm
living my best life i'm eating my
weights you know
and i'm having fun with my boyfriend and
great time with my kid and i have
absolutely no worries i am just getting
a really really happy good place
did this year really put into
perspective who tamar is and who you
want her to be
and who is she well you know i'm just
going to be honest i wasn't telling a
lie
i had just been masking how i felt for
so long that i thought
honestly that i was you know living my
best life you know what i mean
i was in quarantine with my boyfriend
and i was eating whatever i wanted and
watching tv and
sleeping all day and i didn't know that
that was a short sign of depression
you know but you know i i do know that
now
and um yeah now i am totally
um living my best life not just um
in this moment but every single day do
you want to know why
because i make the choice to get up and
try
even when i don't feel like getting out
of bed i still make myself get out of
bed
and um keep it moving i'm telling you i
know it sounds so
cliche and so simple but i promise you
if you keep pushing forward
you'll never know what tomorrow may
bring and i promise you it won't be as
bad as today
tomorrow will not be as bad as today
that i can promise you
yeah i would imagine all the work you've
put into yourself has only made you that
much
better of a mom oh listen it's all in
god's hands
and i have to rely on that and that's it
i can't control
every moment every instant every person
i can only control me and control my
emotions
and that right there my friend is
everything
freedom well kind of on that note and
you can tell me
to shut it if you don't want to talk
about this but i feel like we never
got to hear what you thought of the
family continuing the show without you
and everything you went through well you
know it really wasn't about the family
per se it was more
business related you know i just felt it
was a bit respect disrespectful about a
show that i created
and vince and i funded and you know it
was disrespectful to act like we didn't
exist
it was disrespectful to act like oh this
is just the show that we
we got and we created now it's ours and
you know it was
more disrespectful from a business
standpoint than from anything else
but i love my family we have since all
made amends
and uh god is good and the future is
good
so there you have it would the future
maybe include
a different family show
oh knows
[Laughter]
who knows but i i i'm going to tell you
this
there is a lot of tamar epic television
coming your way
tell me more i will not help you i told
you enough okay
well you you said that you don't really
want to do doc you um
no series anymore you don't want to do
where they're in your life so what kind
of uh
tamar programming is coming our way is
it you helping others
are you so i mean you're you have a
shovel and you are digging aren't you
look i will tell you this i believe in
making amazing television
you know without divulging your you know
your inner dark secrets and making it
all about
drama you know what i mean i think you
know most people have been through
enough this year
to see other people's problems you know
i feel like um we want to see laughter
and fun
and you know how how to you know
go outside again and you know have your
best life
and that's really what i am about i feel
like tv definitely
needs to take a different spin a
different turn and remind people of all
the fun that we used to have and i want
to definitely be
a big part of that do you think braxton
family values is done
i know for a fact that braxton family
values as a family is not done
um i can't really speak on my sisters
but they definitely have my blessing at
whatever endeavors they want to
you know pursue i love this positive you
said you went to shade anonymous and you
are
i did you are recovered you are
it's so good to see what is on the
vision board for the rest of this year
you've got albums coming out you're
returning to performing you got a
million shows in your brain it sounds
like but what
is still the dream oh they definitely
have a space
i don't know i just really want to
evolve you know and i want people to get
to know
um tamar the new tamar um the fun tamar
i mean i'm still
you know all of those things that people
have fallen in love with but i think
you know with life you know i've evolved
and i'm
even better you know i get better with
wine i mean i get better like wine you
know what i mean
so you know i don't know i just really
i really want to have fun and i really
want to
you know bring everyone along for the
ride and
you know be our best selves and live out
listen summer 21 because it's gonna be
an
epic one will it include any dating team
arm
i don't know
you're so funny i'm not dating anyone
right now
um but you know i don't know i'm a
pisces so i love them all so we'll see
i love love the doors open you're
waiting for someone the right person to
walk through
oh yes bruno mars may leave the door
open
there it is always so good catching up
with you i'm excited for bego live i'm
excited for two albums i'm excited for a
million
shows you gave me a lot today tamar
you're gay
that's yes thank you so much yes and
make sure you tune in to bigo live guys
download the app right now and
don't miss the most epic talent show of
your life because guess who will be
judging me tamar she yes
[Music]
you